what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right so continuing on with green
lantern Sunday which we've been doing
this for what feels like forever
we have parallax flash versus Hal Jordan
it is manage the sight to behold it's
pretty amazing because as all the powers
of the flash combined with like the
wrath of parallax right like that's
what's so cool about this parallax is
the fear entity like amplifies the
energies of others but for the most part
is just like the representation of fear
but like flash it's parallax looks
amazing but notice this this is like a
personal battle between these guys
what's so cool about this is that if you
guys you know if when we went over like
the secret origin of Hal Jordan
originally in 1993 how Jordan went crazy
after coast city was destroyed he
declared himself parallax and that was
it
Geoff Johns came along and said actually
he was possessed by the parallax entity
we just didn't know it and that's what's
so cool is because how Jordan knows
parallax like intimately I mean they
know each other in and out parallax
knows what terrifies Hal Jordan the most
but how Jordan knows the weakness of
parallax the problem with this is that
the powers of the flash come into this
and that's what's so cool is because
this is a friend of Barry Allen I'm
sorry friend of Hal Jordan and that's
why parallax possessing one of the
members of the Justice League or
something like that it's such a cool
situation but the conversations between
these two characters and that's what
makes it so interesting the conversation
between these two characters are so
intriguing because one of the things
parallax says is like my ability to
possess Harry Allen allows me to like
communicate with the Speed Force what
would happen if parallax infiltrated the
Speed Force like if he if he managed to
like corrupt of the Speed Force what
would that Speed Force look like and
that's why things like this are so cool
because it kind of asks these questions
no one ever considered before like
nobody ever thought about before you
know that's what's so interesting about
this like it's just one of these really
cool situations where it's just like man
like 400k for example is nothing to do
with the story I am considering a topic
for a Batman story like I'm trying to
flesh out a Batman story there is a
moment with Alfred we're like if it goes
as planned people are gonna like turn
the page or gonna be like oh my god like
there is it's gonna be insane they were
like what it's gonna be one of those
crazy crazy moments but like that's the
kind of thing like these scenarios that
people never think of that people never
consider that never crosses their mind
that's what makes these stories so cool
but for parallax it's not just you're a
character they're like you're a person
that I'm fighting if you are how
jordon like I want you back because
rumor parallax was brought here you know
that mysterious short Guardian person
the person we have no idea who it is at
the moment we know it is now in real
life but like living in the immersion we
don't know who that person is and in
that instance with parallax showing up
like wanting to repossess Hal Jordan
it's so cool because it's like this is
where I belong like I belong in Hal
Jordan like that's where I'm supposed to
be and it's cool because parallax exists
to spread fear that's all it is and when
how Jordan was possessed by parallax he
tried to blink the universe out of
existence and bring it back during zero
hour crisis and time the closest
parallax ever got to spreading fear
across the cosmos I would say the peak
of him was when he possessed Hal Jordan
and so it makes the most sense that he
would want to go back and possess Hal
Jordan again and that's all this really
is it's the whole whole idea of like I
want to repossess you and how Jordan
finally picks up on that
how Jordan finally realizes that like
you want to possess me so then possess
me and initially parallax goes to do
that but this Guardian jumps in the way
well this is this person jumps all the
way he's not a guardian but you know he
jumps of the waves as parallax stop you
are not here to attack Hal Jordan you're
not here to possess him or anything like
that you're here to do my bidding you
are here to do a job that I have that
I've assigned you to and when the
intention of this is of this guardian
guy is to destroy Hal Jordan suddenly we
end up having like all these Lantern
Corps start jumping in you have like the
Indigo trod you have the blue lanterns
you have Larfleeze it shows up it's cool
because remember while this whole thing
is going on everyone's hunting for the
entities a lot of them have already been
found but everyone's hunting for all the
others they're trying to locate them and
trying to figure out where they're at
but at this point we switch over to what
- Sinestro and - Atrocitus because
remember they're on the hunt for the
butcher which is the Red Lantern entity
and the funny thing about this is that
Sinestro is going aligned himself with
Atrocitus for no other reason than the
fact that like hey look maybe somebody
worse than us will get the get the
entities and that's a problem so like
I'd rather he you know on the devil's
right hand then in his path and so we
are going to allow ourselves of
Atrocitus and do what we need to do the
problem with this is that Romar - one of
the yellow lanterns katakana calls him
up and says hey man the webinar that
major yellow lantern ring originally
he's got your daughter on court because
remember cirrhotic not who she bailed
out on the Lantern course and like took
off left and went to go be her own
Lantern and so the result is at this
point in time she's sitting you know in
court she's sitting in the antimatter
universe and then like this guy's like
hey man this guy demands your
and it's like all right look that's
that's why we the worst thing you could
have said was like my presence is
demanded because the coolest thing about
Sinestro more than like how he fights
how Jordan more than him creating his
own Lantern Corps all the kind of stuff
is his arrogance like he's one of those
characters were like normal dig
arrogance but like for me like you look
at Sinestro and it's like yeah man like
he's arrogant and really cocky and it's
amazing like it's it's so cool because
like he's one of the characters like
like I don't know any of you guys if
those guys who were not not like Lantern
fans every stumbling across this video
there are people who loved Sinestro like
they are huge fans of Sinestro actually
I'm curious now that we say it who was
your favorite Lantern like who's your
favorite Lantern of all the lanterns
that exists out there I don't care about
the course who is your favorite Lantern
like is it how Jordan is it Barry Allen
you know I guess when he was a Blue
Lantern is it you know um Atrocitus of
the Red Lanterns like posted let me know
because I'm I'm really kind of curious
but this is intriguing because in the
middle of all this we end up having this
Guardian just kind of show up and when
the question is asked like who are you
and why are you here initially he
doesn't answer you know it's it's kind
of intriguing because one of the things
that happened here was that this
Guardian sort of taking off was done at
the hand of Larfleeze right like
Larfleeze is the orange lantern remember
when it comes to all the other Lantern
cores
Green Lantern's in the Indigo tribe and
the blue lanterns and yada yada yada and
so on you have the emotion of hope or
rage or what have you that spread across
all these individuals with large leaves
it's not like that it channels directly
into him meaning he has the power of a
thousand lanterns and that's what this
does the guy conjures a construct this
saw it like this massive construct and
just smashes the Guardian with it and
it's so cool because initially Hal
Jordan you know contacts of Lula atras
contact Satan walkers and say look man I
need your help man like things are
popping off everything's starting to go
crazy and then like here comes Larfleeze
out of nowhere like out of dude RKO and
no we're just like smashes this guy and
it's the coolest thing because it's just
like - and this is see this is why it's
so cool to me because like when I read
this originally it was my first time
reading it it was probably like seven
months ago is my first time reading it
and like I'm seeing this stuff that
people have known for years and it's
just like this is what you guys have
been reading I've been missing out man
but it's so interesting because what
this Guardian does is he pops back up
onto the scene and says you guys have
served your purpose this was all part of
the plan he didn't defeat me you know
somehow swindle me into a trap like
you've done everything that I wanted you
to do and what I wanted you to do was
take every single person who was
possessed by an
and locate them in one place because in
turn what he does is snatch the entities
out of every single one of those guys
and so this one person is now in
possession of all the lantern entities
that we've discovered so far and the
result is that when the question is
asked yet again who are you like why are
you here we end up finding out that this
guy stands apart from the guardians of
the of the universe he's not one of them
but he was at one point in time this guy
is Crona and this is cool de Oh The
Guardian that looked back at the
beginning of everything and witnessed
the creation of the universe and set the
entirety of the Lantern Corps and really
like good and evil the whole nine yards
set it all in motion this guy is the one
who's responsible for the creation of
the multiverse notice this though this
is something I want you guys to really
really notice here there's the hand in
the window that's that's old that's best
old school content that's back in the
day that's a G double og content that is
back in like the secret origin really
even way back then you know when when
when when crisis on Infinite Earths
happened that's when that was revealed
but that hand right there I still say to
this day that's the hand of dr.
Manhattan that's the hand of dr.
Manhattan creating the entirety of the
universe I say he made it man I say dr.
Manhattan made the universe I'm gonna
stick with that until DC releases the
story and we find out he didn't but I'm
very sure he did in which case now we
got to call him papa Manhattan we got to
call like okay Papa Manhattan like like
whatever you want us to do man like we
go clean our room but it's cool like
this this is a great story like this is
why I love this stuff so much this Green
Lantern stuff why geoff johns is is just
criminally good i mean it's it's it's
stupid how good it is and how
interesting it all comes together but
unless if you guys are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob port you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a light and yeah I
will catch you all later please
[Music]
you